1 ich habe meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
fütterungs folge von dem dies zusammen
mit simon ok und gespielt hast dem rot
schwert habe ich aus den rubinen gemacht
werden sollte haben die ich gesammelt
habe
auch sein rubin schwer hatte komm wir
machen die reinste oder es gibt auch
noch es gibt doch noch saphir oder hey
du macht ihr nicht auch etwas besser
hier zafira aber ist der blaue saphir
schritt machen ja auch ok ok macht den
saphir schnittig versehen aber ein
rätsel auf weil das natürlich dass wir
dann für feuer und für wasser und
abwasser ich mach dich fertig ja aber
ich freu mich verdampfen
das ist so wie bei pokemon das ist hier
die world auf minecraft ein screenshot
man dass man screenshot machen so etwas
aber hier im haus bisschen dass es hier
drin sein helm ausziehen dann sieht man
unsere kraft besser herr brüssel
da ich den helm aus ich habe schon
screenshot private airports wir sind sie
sehen schön aus der puste ports mit
deinen scheiß aus da oben
was ist mit dem komischen baumes ach was
willst du da oben ja ich meine ehemalige
gipfelte dass das wird alles doch nun
hat im creative noch bin ich bin im
normalen modus
ich kann auch nicht durch das portal
alter das portal ist in die parade
tatsache ist ich kann durch es kann ja
jetzt bin ich auch das war das war
obsidian abbauen hier unten
ach so ein wir wollten ihnen das auch so
aus obsidian bauen und zwar in gent mit
table brauchten wir auch noch links ich
möchte meine bei anfang machen jetzt
mein roter baum fahren
samt fahren ich habe er ich war noch
niemals in new york mein flaps einmal
los an meinem eine fts eingebrochen
wo ist da los ist meine geräusches leise
ok aller kräfte konnten hallo hallo
hallo weil man ja meine beine fs
bisschen wie ein bisschen lahm mit
meiner auch meine sehr sehr lang 40 40
ich habe 30
okay was da los ich hab doch gesagt pack
mehr raum auf den service charge gesagt
der server hat zwei 2000/2001 macht den
cup stifter so war also wir brauchen
diese global ich hab so welche abbeißen
krippe das hinkriegen dass ein krieger
das sind zombie der think überwältigt
und brote schwert der gerechtigkeit
es ist auf meinem server war war das
schnelle alles ja aber da hatte ich die
extrem liegt wohl besser dass hier ein
grad von 12 auf großes vielleicht
mustafa akgül ja genau der der es ganz
ganz langsam weil wir aufgerüstet haben
also wer mit übrigens einen mm strater
war noch ein generator den haben wir
jetzt mal hier nicht gefunden warum weiß
ich nicht
wir wollen auch noch eine leckere das
mache die tagsüber hier
ich glaube die sind in deinem dingsda
gebaute gespannt electric hoeneß dafür
braucht man ein eigenes erstmal in ein
randvolles den haben wir doch schon oder
ich weiß nicht ob ich habe schon eine
ehre ist ob schon übrigens meine leute
dass wir mit den sachen hier oben das
alles sortieren können
soja können wir auf jeden fall auch
verknüpfungen an sword kyoto-2 aus taste
an
friendlyway viele sortierung regeln
öffnen dass sein text tabellen geöffnet
na gut fertig ich mache das jetzt
erstmal so einfach zufällig die sache
jetzt ein bisschen sortieren das ist
cool das sind wirklich alles sortiert es
gefällt mir ja wir haben da oben rechts
welche knöpfe das haben uns in den
kommentaren geschrieben hier liest ja
gar keine kommentare
deswegen dass mir das jetzt auch wir
brauchen dafür noch zwei retten und
elektronik des cirque dafür brauchen wir
der coppa kegel habe ich eigentlich noch
elektronik werke dort wird das wär's
wenn ich jetzt noch ein hätte l
das wäre echt optimal
hast du vielleicht ein
ich hab' ich habe eine mini um scherbe
heißt das wer dieser video stein ich
habe auch noch eine mini um scherbe wie
sie wie so was kann man doch mit den
scheinen steuern kann man auch wie alles
mitmachen also mit diesem schein das
kann man es so was wie ergänzung so was
wie gesagt mein joker das heißt wenn wir
irgendwas fehlt sind diamant oder aber
diese - scherben nehmen du kannst du
alles nutzen
ok und wie ging nochmal eine
verzauberung tisch
hast du übrigens hab ich noch glas
gebackener falls wir noch gebrauchen an
den bauern mehr
du kannst erstmals haus noch fertig
bauen alte so viele sachen die wir
machen wollten
was machst du jetzt eigentlich gerade
simon simon sky bis wieder abgespült von
stützt denn mal nicht ab quiksilver
pixel was glaube ich draußen so ein
ausrüster für ihn welche surfing sachen
gleich dort steht mitternacht ein
internet war wieder weg das sehr
steiniger weg genau da bin ich wieder
herr butz er ja hallo herr spiel
gespielt so weit ich habe noch in gent
mit buchs entscheiden ein boxer okay ich
mache mir mal kurz namen aus wie macht
man sich nochmal amboss das altenheim
elementen sondern du machst ein
versorgungs tisch ich mal amboss okay
ich mache beim fahren wieso machst du ne
baum fahre ganz viel aber brauchen die
ganze oper cable ist alles zu machen
ich denke weit voraus ok ich brauche es
komplette eisen was ich hier überall
drin habe dass es silber das ist nicht
inkl
was sind dann kann ich das refinery
zurück machen
hier kann ich nicht nur schade wäre auch
zu schön gewesen
hier ist auch kein eisen tochter
eisenerz hauptsache ich mach einfach
alles hier bitte direkt hier ist auch
noch selber drin
nein da sind eisen machen das ist gut
das ist sehr gut
wahrscheinlich dass nicht theoretisch
schon hier mit was sich aus vier grad
alles habe wir brauche ich überhaupt von
diesem komischen blötschkopp 3 aber
nicht sicher er ist es nicht sehe ich
mein ich hab mein agent gemacht was
nugget das ist sowas wie gold nicht
glauben was was soll ich damit
bei mäzen amboss hab ich einfach mal
dahin pakt am einsatz erschwert drauf
manch jetzt fällt die ganzen sachen
drauf
ich mache alles schön feuerschutz kann
ich da nicht drauf packen
diese kann die stärke draufpacken stärke
1 haye der conti da weiß nicht was er
redet so kann ich auf meinen schweren
die stärke draufpacken
wieso kannst du das licht ja das wird
sich aber gerne
hat das vielleicht hat es damit zu tun
na gut tun kann ich jetzt nicht mitmacht
nimmt regnet es ungemütlich ja wir
brauchen vielleicht mal dach simon ja
ich kann nicht alles auf einmal doch ich
habe mich aber daran glaube ich an drauf
aber übrigens noch die baum fahren jetzt
kupfer redstone ist ja auch noch vom ja
cool was kann ich tun muss um die machen
ich mach mal ganz zu schweigen ein
bisschen lauter geräusche manchmal auf
20 ich mag diese klopfgeräusche von
minecraft zu gerne macht wird das
projekt aus europa cable breiter front
okay okay was was sollen sie einen
kommentar schreiben ob die us pop
geräusche minecraft so geil finden was
ein stopp gereicht dieses outfit
ich glaube das war auch mein gott
preisen sommer ins bett gehen
doch ich bin direkt allerdings auch
harry feier augen bräuchte keeper die
sind ein pärchen das habe ich einen
pinguin sie lieben sich
er dreht schon im bett
mensch du schreist immer so rum werden
direkt mit ihm reden bin so hast du
einfach so rein ins bett genommen weder
auf der frei
du wolltest immer dass es das haus zu
bauen ist es nie gekriegt
doch ich mache das jetzt was für ein
gegenstand und es selber nicht im bett
was für dach willst du ihn haben was
finden was ihr material auf das gleiche
holz wir hatten da doch schon angefangen
guckt da muss erst mal die balken dafür
dichtring für klein beginnt jetzt erst
mal noch darum und macht das neue dach
würde ich sagen
was anderes als dass wieder alles was
ich habe keine ahnung was nennt man mal
so ich mache jetzt ein elektriker
electric verbräuche electric wenn es
aber der kann ja schon längst machen man
braucht nur noch zwei redstone für das
fichtenholz ja okay wenn man denen der
mitte darüber den circuit unternehmens
redstone mitte ok electric von das haben
jetzt auch okay als electric furness
mails raytheon generate aber den finde
ich ja hier nicht drin